ça ne passe pas que la chine soit
adoptée une loi sur la sécurité
nationale
pour ces députés pro démocratie c'est la
pire attaque contre l'autonomie de hong
kong
mais la chef du gouvernement local
assure que cette décision est la
bienvenue au nom du calme et de la
stabilité
après une année de perturbations et de
violence dit elle référence à lamastre
contestation qui est ce territoire
semi-autonome à sa bénédiction
s'ajoutent c'est un voeu de voir s'en
remettre
noir central chinois pour arriver à
imposer une loi sur la sécurité
nationale
après 23 ans d'échec karina m'assure que
les droits comme celui de manifester et
les libertés seront toujours protégé la
peur persiste une loi controversée
annoncée pendant que la coved 19
monopolise l'attention de la communauté
internationale
si jp lui lance un défi pour voir si
elle va se porter à notre défense assure
ce militant de longue date
le canada est au nombre de ceux qui font
part de leur préoccupation pour les
états unis la loi sur la sécurité
nationale sera un coup fatal porté à
l'autonomie promise par la chine pour
hong kong lors de la rétrocession par
les britanniques à washington qui lui
demande de reconsidérer une position
qualifiée de désastreuse pékin répond
qu' aucun pays n'a le droit de regard
dans ce dossier d'ailleurs sa loi vise
également tout ce qu'il pourra
considérer comme une ingérence étrangère
mais la pression sur la chine deviendra
aussi de l'intérieur des pro démocratie
déterminés à se faire entendre
malgré les limites de rassemblement
imposé par la distanciation social ici
annick bureaud réseau canada